[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es eine motiv torte eine
my little pony motiv torte das ist eine
kinderserie die die immer ganz gerne
schaut und sie hat sich gewünscht eine
apple deckt orte das ist das gelbe pony
ja was ich von der sendung halte weiß
ich nicht so ganz die schreien immer so
viel ab und so darf das gucken nicht
immer aber ich glaube my little pony
entstand sowieso zuerst glaube ich
korrigiert mich wenn ich falsch liege
aus den spielfiguren und dann kam es in
serie und die spielfiguren diesem schon
süß also kleine süße ponys in
verschiedenen farben und apple jack ist
das gelbe pony das mache ich jetzt heute
und zwar mache ich jetzt dafür eine
gelbe torte mit zitronengeschmack mag
die er nämlich auch ganz gerne
und dann wird diese torte die kinder
geburtstagstorte und ich glaube ihre
freundinnen werden sich bestimmt auch
freuen
für den teig nämlich 350 gramm zucker
eine prise salz etwas vanille extrakt
zitronen passte und gelbe lebensmittel
verpasste jeweils 150 gramm
sonnenblumenöl und buttermilch 200 gramm
mehl backpulver und einer mandel dann
nehme ich jetzt erst die eier die
kommenden die rührschüssel das ist auf
der man so röhl trägt den ich gerne
mache etwas salz und zucker
hier könnt ihr auch direkt bisschen
vanille dazugeben und für den
zitronengeschmack bedrohen passte oder
den bio zitronen und treibt die schale
ab und da müssen nur darauf achten dass
man die schale auch erzählen kann
das steht da auch mal dran
jetzt schön für fünf bis sechs minuten
richtig cremig rühren
ich habe jetzt nur noch ganze mandel und
die werde ich in der zeit schon mal auf
einmal
wunderschön sieht die masse jetzt aus
dass er noch ein bisschen rühren gebe es
hier auch gleich die verpasste dazu da
ist auch echt immer wichtig dass ihr
verpasste nehmt und keine flüssigen
farben denn die flüssige farbe die
verändert einfach zur seite die
konsistenz des teiges das heißt hier
einfach verpasste nehmen die könnt ihr
wirklich für von dort neben marzipan
teig creme und es verändert die
konsistenz einfach nicht und den
geschmack auch nicht
[Musik]
wird schon mal super aus ich habe jetzt
hier schon backpulver mit mehl vermischt
und kann auch schon meine backform
vorbereiten
ich nehm ist sie ja mein bett mit einer
dauer back folie und stelle zu den
tortenring einfach auf 26 zentimeter ein
[Musik]
das kann ich hier noch die beiden
flüssigkeiten dazugeben muttermilch und
ganz kurz nur einrühren
[Musik]
und das mehl mit dem backpulver dazu 7
ist auch nur ganz kurz einrühren und
jetzt direkt in die backform einfüllen
und backen und ich kann die zwischenzeit
dann nutzen und schon mal ein bisschen
was für die creme herstellen
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es auch eine zitrone füllung
ein level curt dafür nämlich 50 g zucker
1 150 gramm butter und 50 gramm
zitronensaft und die schale von den
zitronen die sind auch mit verzehrbar
und im prinzip kann man sich das level
rezept wirklich super merken es ist von
allem immer 50 gramm
und so blickt er auf 50 gramm als hat er
immer das rezept im kopf ein viertel
teelöffel stärke kommt jetzt hier noch
dazu ich kann jetzt hier schon alle
zutaten zum pferd bringen ist nämlich
zuerst die zitrone da habe ich die
schale ab schreibe ich die schale
frank wir sagen wenn schon da rein kommt
da kommst ex bild kommen eine runde mit
den schon in der hand dann sieht man
genau bei uns ziehen alle ihre schuhe
aus ganz vorbildlich und eine apple
sektor my little pony
danke frank meine damen und herren zu
machen jetzt immer so immer wenn einer
in die küche rein läuft das einmal
durchs bild noch dann seht ihr was ihr
den tag über so abgeht ok es immer gar
nicht mal so viele leute jetzt nämlich
nach dem zitronensaft und da stelle ich
einfach in den topf auf die waage 50
gramm
deswegen gebe ich auch all meine zutaten
immer in gramm an also auch
flüssigkeiten weil es echt viel
einfacher ist jetzt braucht ihr keine
messbecher sondern können auch mit der
waage arbeiten und die ausgedrückte
zitronenschale kommt jetzt noch als
spülmaschinen direkt in die spülmaschine
dann habt ihr wirklich komplett
verwertet von der schale über den saft
bis zum rest das war schon alles
erledigt kommen die übrigen zutaten rein
also das sei die stärke und der zucker
die butter noch nicht die zutaten kurz
verrühren und dann bei mittel hoher
hitze rühren und ganz kurz aufkochen
lassen
[Musik]
fertig und jetzt streich es hierdurch
ein hase damit mögliche klumpen entfernt
werden können hier gebe ich jetzt die
kalte butter dazu und dröse ein dadurch
kühlt das land gehört ab und wird auch
schön cremig und normalerweise mache ich
immer gleich eine große portion die
doppelte oder dreifache
denn das land gehört jetzt auch ein
toller brotaufstrich richtig lecker wenn
man einfach in quark ein rührt also da
können dann wirklich eine große menge zu
bereiten und etwa eine woche im
kühlschrank lagern
wenn ich das jetzt eingeführt habe denke
ich die creme ablassen abkühlen wartet
auf den kuchen und struck mir schon mal
eine schablone aus das pony
[Musik]
der kuchen ist abgekühlt das land gehört
ist abgekühlt jetzt gibt es noch die
creme dazu da mache ich jetzt meine
mutter grimm da gibt es auch das rezept
bereits auf einem kanal dafür brauche
ich weiß etwas salz und zucker butter
die es bei die habe ich einfach fein
gerieben damit sie schnell weich wird
aus dem kühlschrank butter zucker und
vanille extrakt und da macht das jetzt
einfach so ihr nehmt das eiweiß mit dem
salz und zucker und vanille extrakt und
erhitzt es über einem kochenden wasser
bat für etwa zehn minuten
ich mache das jetzt einfach hier in der
kenwood weil ich da diese funktion habt
stellt die auf 70 grad und auch zehn
minuten und danach wird das ganze wieder
kalt gerührt
hier kann ich jetzt schon die weiche
butter mit dem puderzucker verrühren
während jetzt die eier creme kalt
gerührt wird geht natürlich auch alles
mit dem handrührgerät aber so habe ich
einfach die hände frei für andere dinge
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich so weit und kann die
abgekühlte masse mit der buttercreme
verrückt also mit der butter verrühren
damit ist eine mutter krank wird und da
wirklich schönen lange rühren damit
weckt er abgekühlt ist ansonsten
schmilzt euch nämlich die butter und
wenn es zu kalt ist wiederum gewinnt so
ein bisschen mit flockig ist aber nicht
schlimm da könnte es dann retten indem
er einfach das ganze aufs wasser bat
stellt ob es war schön einrühren fertig
kurz zur seite
ich habe ich jetzt den abgekühlten
tortenboden und ich hatte den jetzt auch
kurz im gefrierfach nach dem kompletten
abkühlen kühlschrank geht auch dann
lässt er sich besser schneiden und habe
jetzt auch den neuen tortenring genommen
und ihr seht ist es wirklich nichts
ausgelaufen obwohl ich den nicht
eingeschlagen habe also echt super gut
gelöst habe ich ihn schon
ich habe schon gelöst und hier ist meine
schablone dem ich jetzt ausgedruckt und
ausgeschnitten sehr gut passt perfekt
und dieses stückchen die ich hier übrig
habt die sätze ich hier noch dran was
ich jetzt aber zuerst machen werde ist
die torte zu erfüllen also einmal
halbieren
da kommt jetzt die lemon curt füllung
rein wie schön sie ist wenn ich übrigens
lemon gehört mache als brotaufstrich
nämlich weniger butter und wenn ich es
als torten füllung mache nämlich etwas
mehr butter damit sie eben auch etwas
fester wird
dann setze ich jetzt ein deckel wieder
drauf und schneidet den kuchen zu so ist
gut und die füße die sätze ich dann
gleich noch dran also jetzt hier einmal
außen rum
[Musik]
zum ankleben der beine nehme ich jetzt
hier die buttercreme und die könnt ihr
auch wenn ihr wollt über das level curt
noch streichen
jetzt weggelassen eigentlich wollte es
machen aber jetzt vergessen dass es hier
so ein bisschen drunter und hier habe
ich jetzt dieses stück für den schweiß
auf und nimmt dieses für die beine und
dann einfach anlegen und zu steigen
[Musik]
das habe ich hier alles soweit fertig
und nehme die schablone mal runter und
kann jetzt zuerst mal die torte mit der
buttercreme einstreichen und dann kühl
stellen damit sie einfach mal schön fest
wird denn so ist jetzt erst mal noch ein
bisschen zu locker
die reste hier werden nicht
weggeschmissen werden vernascht ich
werde jetzt hier alles erstmal der
schüssel sammeln und später
wahrscheinlich einfach noch so zitronen
kugeln dazu machen direkt für die erste
kühlung der kuchen war etwa eine stunde
im kühlschrank ich habe mich
mittlerweile umgezogen weil es mir
einfach zu blättern wurde und jetzt ist
doch schön fest und ich kann jetzt die
vorlage noch mal nehmen noch mal drum
herum schneiden so ein bisschen exakte
und dann nochmal tiefen restliche butter
creme verwenden
und jetzt gerade hier so teuren nochmal
genauer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so lasse ich das coni jetzt jetzt kommt
es noch mal in die kühlung und ich werde
erst mal wieder dran arbeiten
denn heute bin ich hätte aber heute ist
nicht alle tage ich komm wieder keine
frage die buttercreme war nämlich jetzt
über nacht im kühlschrank habe ich
einfach die teekanne war umgang mit
bisschen wasser wasser weggeschüttet und
der sitzt rüber gestellt so bekommt ihr
nämlich auch kalte butter ganz schnell
warm also die torte auf ein kickboard
setzen auf den schwanz mit der warmen
buttercreme dran
[Musik]
das habe ich hier noch mal meine vorlage
das pony das ist nicht ganz gelb sondern
eher so ein helles pastellige orange und
die farbe mische ich mir jetzt aus
sondern und dafür möchte ich jetzt etwas
gelb rot und weiß viel brauche ich nicht
das ist ja wirklich eine schöne kleine
torte weiß verwende ich damit so ein
bisschen pass der liga wird und droht
damit es auch ausgeht
und natürlich das geld ich mache erst
mal eine kleine menge und dann die große
das habe ich hier viel farbtöne dieser
farbton ist für den körper
der helle ist hierfür der schweiz
das gelb ist hierfür die umrandung und
das dunklere orange ist für die
umrandung des körpers wie packe ich
jetzt einfach bis zur verwendung
luftdicht ein und startete jetzt zuerst
mal mit dem körper
jetzt werde ich zuerst einmal den körper
über zins hat schon gesagt aber
zwischendurch ist soviel passiert ich
habe mit rob basel einen podcast gedreht
wir haben ein video gedreht
ja also podcast aufgenommen video
gedreht das sieht man oft nicht in den
videos aber es passiert immer so viel
zwischendurch und jetzt soll ich hier
den von dort aus schön dünn auf etwas
becker stärke da braucht man wirklich
auch noch ganz wenig und wenn ihr jetzt
sagt das ist mir bisher zu aufwendig
gewesen und geradezu mit der kultur mit
dem zurecht schneiden dann macht doch
einfach eine runde torte füllt sie und
überzieht sie mit dieser buttercreme und
dann könnt ihr euch nämlich die
schablone nehmen und hier aus dem
fondant jetzt die umrisse ausschneiden
und drauflegen
das geht dann ein bisschen einfacher so
fand ich jetzt aber ein bisschen süße
wollte ich etwas beides zeigen und den
knochen wirklich sehr gut sehr dünn
ausrollen davon dann habe ich mit shea
butter nicht mit ein paar palmfett da
ist wirklich super elastisch das dürfte
schon reichen
das muss ich selber immer so ein
bisschen auf die kleine schablone
schauen
das heißt hier oben kommen acht jahre
darüber dass noch aus der farbe bis zum
schwänzen
okay ich mache es mal etwas großzügiger
drüber und das ist natürlich die
schwierigkeit gerade bei diesem kleinen
ponys jetzt überall so kommt dazu kommen
jetzt ist einfach wirklich die
schwierigkeit hier überall diese kanten
zu glätten dann hinter euch jetzt ein
bisschen zeit macht es schön vorsichtig
und schneidet einfach die reste weg
[Musik]
und dann könnt ihr euch hier einfach ein
bisschen model werkzeug zur hilfe nehmen
und wirklich gerade an den stellen an
denen mit den fingern jetzt nicht so
dran kommt so leicht andrücken und
nochmal schön diese kanten glätten
[Musik]
die übrigen habe ich ein bisschen
auseinander geschnitten so weiß ich
nämlich ungefähr was muss jetzt das
heißt gerade hier kann ich jetzt etwas
wegschneiden
[Musik]
um schon mal an zeichnen und jetzt kann
ich auch schon den schweifen über 10 mit
fondant
[Musik]
soll ich hier den haaransatz legt die
schablone drauf und schneide jetzt der
schablone entlang hier das geld weg
aus dem dunklen orange habe ich jetzt
hier streifen aufgeschnitten also
einfach hier mit einem pizza rat da kann
ich sie nämlich wirklich sehr sehr dünn
ausschneiden und dann nehme ich jetzt
hier meine schablone und schlägt hier
die streifen drauf und klebt sie dann
mit ersten kleber dran das ist jetzt ein
bisschen mehr arbeit da könnt ihr euch
gerne etwas mehr zeit nehmen
ihr könnt aber auch wenn jetzt ganz
einfach machen wollt mit einem stift
malen also mit einem lebensmittel stift
[Musik]
jetzt ist das auge drin dafür nehme ich
auch einfach die schablone legte drauf
und schneit dann erstmal weiß aus dann
schwarz und das grün mal ich dann so ein
bisschen dran oder nehmen einfach einen
grünen kleinen strang
ich glaube ich nehme kleinen grünen
strand ich lasse jetzt doch übrigens den
hut weg denn ich hatte doch dann holt
auch erhöhen müssen mit kuchen egal ich
wollte nicht so kompliziert machen aber
irgendwie doch jetzt so ein bisschen
viel detailarbeit
[Musik]
programmiert ist fertig mittlerweile ist
es schon spät ach ja die sonnigen rund
1820 ist schon okay sag mal wie gefällt
dir die torte für ihre also für alle die
ganz gut passen also für mich ist
ja du bist ja auch aus dem my little
pony alter raus ja gefällt sie die
ränder wird ihr auch bestimmt gefallen
ich hoffe es also ich würde auch wenn
man so von oben drauf schaut sieht sie
doch ziemlich süßes aus und ihnen
schmeckt sie wie gesagt nach zitrone
ich muss aber echte dazu sagen also als
ich mit dem video angefangen habe habe
ich mir noch so gedacht ich mach es
einfach alle vier ponys denn ich mache
eine ganz einfache technik im endeffekt
hat sich doch länger gedauert als
gedacht weil ich eben diese kontur
ausgeschnitten habe ihr könnt wirklich
auch einfach eine runde trotte machen
und dann ans aufleger darauf arbeiten es
geht viel viel schneller ich fand es so
ist halt irgendwie cooler aber es halt
doch ziemlich zeitaufwändig ich glaube
beim nächsten mal würde ich nicht machen
wird wirklich nur eine runde oder eckige
torte machen und einfach die kontur
machen mit einem aufleger zumal er dann
den aufleger auch so war vorbereiten
können ich hoffe euch hat das video
trotzdem gefallen und ihr macht
vielleicht die torte nach auf diese art
und weise könnt ihr natürlich auch alle
anderen ponys und alle anderen figuren
machen
ich wünsche euch jedenfalls viel spaß
dabei und bis zum nächsten mal
jetzt tue was er in kühlschrank und dann
kann er morgen kindergeburtstag feiern
ich hab's probiert morgen leider erst
mit ihren zwei freundinnen da kann man
sie wecken feierabend
[Musik]